but first up she's a political
commentator and author of resistance is
futile
the trumpeting left lost its collective
mind my good friend of me and Coulter is
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you you are more powerful you're
like Wonder Woman if Wonder Woman was
the villain but really all over the news
I hear them talking about the Coulter
veto what whatever Donald Trump does if
you don't say it's okay no good is that
promise you the country would be run
much better if you had a veto over don't
my Donald well you kind of do I mean he
was ready to he was ready to go along
with what they passed on look crazy that
I expect a president to keep the promise
he made every day for 18 months right no
it's not just it's the base that's what
happened you had him making this what
are you looking at I'm looking this guy
he's holding the card behind the counter
which is an interesting place to put it
if I was Superman he could see through
it I'll do all the talking
well no it's crazy that the base is what
as rebelled here and they can take me as
a stand-in for the base but that's all I
am a member of the base yeah well that's
very modest I mean you said today that
uses route suite when Trump capitulated
on the wall he said good news for
Herbert Walker Bush as of today he is no
longer the biggest wimp ever to serve as
president so let me get this straight
you you were convinced that Donald Trump
was the guy you voted for him Donald
Trump her and now you're finding you're
finding out he's a lying con men what
was your first clue
I mean okay this is the thing not only
okay I'm very stupid girl fine but that
was actually a selling point with chomp
I mean you can make fun of me for also
writing and Trump we Trustee floor of us
awesome look we've been lied to over and
over and over again by politicians by
respectable people by people like Mitt
Romney and George Bush Obama and Clinton
we're going to we're going to protect
your jobs to the same and if I could
just say for a second to an audience
that is not wild about me
I think this build the wall line has has
become him and it sounds like true cat
Hilary your locker up it isn't that
you're being played this is as Bernie
Sanders said a Koch brothers idea this
is lots of cheap labor pouring into this
country is good for employers it's not
good for employees you know who wants it
the Koch brothers they want it Rupert
Murdoch once and my party wants it why
hasn't the point is that the war don't
want it it's all of mass immigration
it's our legal information it's no II
verify it but well is it big part of it
at but the reason you're being played to
have everybody keep acting like this is
some sort of racist thing you're well
working-class wages have gone down okay
middle-class wages have been stagnant
it's great for the rich it's good for
you okay but the bad for people who work
okay but the point was the wall won't
stop that of course of course it would
most people will come here from Mexico
don't come for the board they come for
jobs they come on a plane and then just
stay that's absolutely not true what you
say walls don't work tell it to
Netanyahu yes right they build a wall to
stop suicide bombers I've never had my
gardener is once not once tried to blow
me
[Applause]
northern side those walls were inside
with her stop African illegal immigrants
coming in and taking jobs went from a
huge problem to zero no immigrants all
right and Mexico will pay for it what
happened look in Trump's defense he
never said they would prepay floored he
explained very clearly how it would be
done he will not work so now he laid
this out very clearly he said they would
believe your sex remittances Mexicans in
this country both legal and illegal send
back 25 billion every year every year
that's enough for the full wall you put
a 10% tax on that as he recommended and
he put it in his immigration policy
paper in ten years you've paid for a
twenty five billion dollar wall okay but
today he was talking about how we never
said it was a wall from coast to coast
that's exactly why is he you know first
it was a wall then it was a fence then
it was just I guess cones I think maybe
thoughts and prayers is what if we could
get thoughts and prayers to work tonight
but let me just ask you about his state
of mind he said the other day he said I
see a lot of the Democrats almost all of
them this just speaks to his mind and
this is what I want to ask you why you
like this guy like he's starting with a
giant lie that the Democrats that the
end of the quote is our breaking I see a
lot of the Democrats almost all of them
are breaking saying look walls are good
walls are good no Democrats are saying
that that's exactly the opposite of
their position their leaders said it's
an immorality so he starts with a lie I
see a lot of the Dems he's in the middle
of his own sentence when he then goes
almost all of them you see he builds on
his own life from two seconds before he
is not [ __ ] saying
he convinces himself of his own reality
that is so dangerous Oh tell me that oh
he's so coarse he's so vulgar he makes
things up no I went into this fully
clear-eyed again we liked that about him
because respectable people who listen to
you like Senator doesn't live in reality
because I thought I'm not I we thought
that he wouldn't care what the elites
thought and he'd actually keep his
promises on this and and by the way
in fact Nancy Pelosi didn't say we need
a barrier at the border chuck schumer
did obama said it over and over they
certainly weren't talking about that but
things aside I didn't know let's suck up
to Wall Street and they want cheap
nannies and the Republicans said let's
suck up to Chamber of Commerce we want
cheap nannies okay all of you are being
screwed by the way it chief labor isn't
so bad for me I'm not as rich as he is
but I'm not doing badly my landscaping
is beautiful there is not a bit of slime
on my pool it's good for me but I care
about my fellow American class make it
up to you in bed tonight
[Applause]
tonight I'll be Kellyanne and you be
George so he also said this week I know
more about technology than anybody know
I find that really charming so and if
Obama did that he had the best words he
said he's the most more presidential
Lincoln um I could go on and on it makes
me laugh that's fine I like that about
him
just keep your promise and I'm right
back in his camp okay so let me ask you
about the other big story today Roger
stone was arrested I would agree with
you it was an over-the-top arrest but
you know what about the law you say
you're okay with these fun lies that's
not a lie it's puffery it's exaggerated
okay no one thinks oh yeah this guy I'm
the best or an insane clinical
narcissist but okay that shouldn't be
President but okay give you that one
what about Lies that really matter like
we found out that every time he said and
we've all seen the clips on the news
reset I had the no contact with Russian
nothing we stayed away we didn't we know
that that's a plain lie that's a kind of
a consequential lie isn't it now that we
know he was he was trying to build a
tower in Moscow up until the election we
know any of this and I don't think we do
know there's a factory Clinton paid
through her campaign 30 million dollars
to Russian officials to get dirt on
Trump if the whole future GPS story
she paid that to get Russian dirt on
wrong if she's going to be walking
around having moles then I really don't
want to hear what Trump having as you
didn't pay Russia she wasn't working
with Russia he is working with a foreign
course there's evidence mower has 37 I'm
telling you how to get Trump he promised
something for 18 months and he lied
about it that's how you get
Trump it's not this Russian nonsense you
are some wasting time
well we're okay you know I remember your
boyfriend Ronald Reagan saying Russia
was an evil empire mr. Gorbachev tear
down the wall what do you think Ronald
Reagan would think right now I think he
would like us being so cozy with these
lunatics it's not the Soviet Union
anymore we didn't win it it still did
win it but it's still Russia you know
not that we you know we are not living
under the threat of first of all the
president over okay today
Venezuela this is the front page of the
New York Times a Venezuela okay they
have a guy of fine an opposition leader
who finally stood up and we are backing
him and Russia warned us to back off
because they're backing the dictator
this was the Monroe Doctrine this is our
backyard and Russia is now telling us to
back off of what goes on in Venezuela
because they know they can the Patriot
well I'm not just the patriot as you
said I'm also the Donald Trump advisor
and I'm also telling him to back off
because you know what is more in our
backyard than even Venezuela Texas
Arizona California about those states
and what's being done to them it always
gets back to hating Mexicans that did
[Applause]
you know bookkeeper I don't work at
Wendy's I'm not a reefer truck going to
declare ones were being screwed over is
Trump going to declare a national
emergency
nobody said in three weeks what's he
gonna do has got to read a constitution
to him he's the commander-in-chief his
job is at your last question a lot of
people are saying you should be the one
to run for president would you do that
I'm against women working so I can't
everybody and Coulter let the jousting
begin thank you Charlie see you later
yes woman okay
you